Is anyone else going to bed tonight
knowing that you will not be able to sleep,
that you're gonna be glued to the television,
that you are going to be praying for people that you've never met
in Florida? I just, like,
we have family in Florida,
but, like,
not in Tampa. We have my in laws and Naples,
they evacuated. We have family in Orlando,
Florida, which people are going there to evacuate,
but it's still gonna be not great.
I'm just constantly scrolling TikTok.
I watch this mom with this incredible, like,
almost like Pinterest hack of how to prepare a kid's life vest.
Like, this is not normal.
But of course, she had everything she needed,
and she was so prepared with, like,
the glow sticks and the waterproof bag with all their information,
and all I'm thinking is like,
oh, my god.
Like, this is the same eerie,
unbelievable fear and feeling that I get when I watch people put, like,
bulletproof plates in their kids backpacks for school.
Like, this is not normal.
And I'm just so on edge watching it.
Like, this is right after Helene. I'm just so scared.